klar wird es reicht häufig gehe ich
werde dich darum bitten zu gehen kann
man nur weiter draußen kann später
kommen ich habe den letzten tagen sehr
viel lacht und vielleicht wieder
bekommen wenn die nämlich gebeten hat
auf ein gewisses video zu reagieren das
video um das es geht hat in den letzten
tagen für sehr viel tumult gesorgt hat
auch sehr lange auf platz eins in trance
belegt die rede ist wenn man auch von
fabrizio giordano bei dsds und ganz kurz
doch falls jemand von der es erst selbst
das irgendwie sieht und meinem video nie
gerne unternehmen lassen möchte
vergangenheit zu langer zeit hat dsds
videomaterial von mir verwendet oder
nachzufragen also wenn du zum beispiel
als teichpumpe bei mir im garten
anfangen willst oder so dann ist das
genau der richtige gesang
gleiches recht für alle das video
öffentlich ich bin von der position
genau hast du dich jetzt absichtlich als
frau geschminkt so zurecht oder bist du
so ja nein ich glaube es war nicht
absichtlich ich denke mal hat sich aus
versehen als frauen schminkt da fängst
du mich schon an leute ich hab ein
bisschen außen rum schon was über diesen
auftritt gesehen ich habe auch das
interview von fabrice giordano mit
mattlack gesehen da hat er also fabrizio
eingeläutet dass viele diesen auftritt
herum fake ist und dass die jury sehr
gemein züge waren ja ganz ehrlich also
allein der einstieg schon so hast du
dich mit absicht so angezogen das hat
schon mega respektlos
[Musik]
das kann man doch nicht machen das ist
eine show die bestimmt millionen von
leuten im fernsehen sehen und wenn dann
jemand auftritt der familien angezogen
ist und sagt dass er schwul ist dann
nach oben modells abzuspielen
alte wie respektlos ist das und die
schuhe an sehr teuer
[Musik]
kann man ja den guten start gehen das
auch kraß history dazu ist er hatte
irgendwie jetzt vor gar nicht allzu
langer als hätten und vielleicht auch
ein schlaganfall was an der art und hat
selbst jetzt gerade irgendwelche geräte
in den ordnung besser werden zu können
kann auch ohne wohl schulen nicht gehen
und ich will kein unsinn erzählen aber
ich meine das zweite mal dass er in dem
interview gesagt hat dass er irgendwie
ein bisschen dazu geprüft wurde sich so
krass anzuziehen und hat sie jemand der
sehr schwer behindert ist jetzt gerade
das ist er an den hohen schuhen laufen
zu müssen
ich weiß nicht warum ich nicht in
bequemen schuhen würde ich besser aus
dann bequem ist da aber nein man manche
das durch was den frauenschuh ich mir
das eigentlich gar nicht anschauen
das ist so gemein ganz ehrlich ich weiß
auch nicht ob die jury wirklich von
natur und vom charakter aus so gemein
ist dass die leute so was an kopf weil
das ist wirklich aspekt los oder ob die
das viel schaum machen müssen aber
selbst wenn es nur für die show ist was
von der show ist das in der es nur darum
geht leute bloßzustellen und zu
blamieren und zu erniedrigen
was weiß ich davon wer deutscher meister
ein hip hop ist aber eher pop ist keine
sportart wie fußball oder so das ist
eine kultur die aus verschiedenen
elementen besteht so kann ich sagen dass
ich 16 mal deutscher meister in deutsch
geworden
21 personen also das habe ich nicht
krasser unterschied so sieht der junge
ohne schminke aus müssen ganz normaler
kerl
was führt wunder ein kandidat kommt zu
dir zuerst die komische aus man macht
sich lustig und dann kann auch nicht so
gut sehen überraschung also ich kann ich
mal sagen wie ich dir es bisher
verstanden haben für mich ist dies so
klar am ende kommen ein paar aus die
auch gut singen können und so und das
alles schön und gut aber niemand würde
sich diese oben anschauen wenn er
einfach nur leute sind die gut singen so
und deswegen wenn da leute mehr oder
weniger bewusst weiß ich nicht
eingeladen um vorgeführt zu werden
einfach damit man über die lachen kann
sagt otto h
der stellte man der kann nicht singen
ich weiß nicht finde es wird also ich
habe keinen spaß daran zu sehen wie
leute erniedrigt werden
[Musik]
achtet mal auf die art und weise wie das
video gemacht dass leute welche
anwendungen verwendet werden zum
beispiel jetzt gerade ein bild von amy
winehouse musik mega fertig aussieht
dann auch die soundeffekte im
hintergrund so die kommentare von der
jury ich finde aber zeigen sich für mich
zumindest ein klares bild dafür dass es
hierbei darum geht einfach die person zu
erniedrigen oder zumindest sich
ausschließlich oder größtenteils über
sie lustig zu machen und ich persönlich
finde dass es nicht so gut
das ist so unangenehm leute ich schon
echt leider keinen fernseher sollte und
warum sollte man sich das anschauen also
ich habe mich nicht gut dabei ich mich
schlecht für mich schlecht für die
personen die da so niedergemacht wird
mein ziel des ernst oder willst du es
warst erforderliche trete vor
millionenpublikum und sehr aufgeregt und
dann solche kommentare und wenn wir ganz
kurz man die kommentare beim
videoschauen gesagt macht heute das ist
alles fake schaut euch mal ein video mit
diesem favorit yuan und ihr seht die
wahrheit die frage soll in welcher teil
des werkes das alles abgesprochen und
die reaktion von ihm sind auch fake das
glaube ich nämlich nicht was mir sehr
gut vorstellen könnte ist das dsds die
leute in der richtung post und antreibt
dass die möglichst lächerlich aussehen
ich möglichst komisch darstellen schief
singen wenn sie von der jury treten bei
polar für das ein paar solides zuhause
sehen sich dann ein bisschen besser
fühlen wenn sie über andere lachen
können denen es noch schlechter geht
abstoßend jetzt der gesang auch es hat
so kurzer zeit wie helium kurz angehört
als ob du so einen luftballon grad sowie
deine erste edition
[Musik]
trotz weiter ich weiß echt nicht leute
ich weiß es nicht das was ist das
konzept dahinter wurde ihm gesagt dass
er die jury beleidigen soll damit die
ihnen dann noch mehr zurück beleidigen
oder hat er sich so sehr an gegangen
gefühlt dass er so persönlich geworden
ist sollte für pietro lombardi gegenüber
ich glaube nämlich jahr hat nämlich in
dem interview gesagt dass er persönlich
auch noch sehr angegangen wurde also das
ist noch szenen gab die nicht gezeigt
wurden wo er persönlich sehr angegangen
wurde und das ja auch deswegen so
aggressiv reagiert hat ist das ist dass
die leute meine erste in meiner ersten
18 jahre jung das darf man nicht
vergessen aber lustig dass er sich
rechtfertigt sich klaus erst quasi der
große juror bei dsds bekannt und ist
immer in dieser sendung dann kommt die
matrei und wird was an kopf und er
rechtfertigt sich ja auch noch das heißt
wir dass er das annimmt so als kritik
oder als angriffen das ist
wahrscheinlich auch so sieht aber ich
weiß echt nicht leute ich stehe sehr auf
papier von paradiso in den inn stories
von baby und so entsteht auch ein paar
youtuber der wirklich mega cool in den
videos wie du bist ja jetzt so ich habe
da 100 millionen mal besser gesungen als
du sogar also diese zahl gibt es gar
nicht zu sehen als airplay scheiße wenn
ich jetzt unterbrechen
ich schreibe mir die kommentare wie sich
das für euch anfühlt dass hier gerade zu
sehen also dass sein ehrlich also ist
auch nicht schön wenn dir das gefühl
haben das ist gute unterhaltung und ihr
fühlt euch dabei gut und finde ich
danach gut und irgendwas cooles und
bereits damals gesehen das mich wissen
und wenn ihr es nicht so sehr um so ein
komischer schreien würde mich echt
interessieren weil für mich ist das
einfach nicht gefallen das aber okay das
kann man auch sagen also man muss nicht
jemanden verloren was nicht gute es
sollen aber so persönliche angriffe wie
sie
dort kamen ich bin übrigens man sollte
die erst jetzt und ich besonders in
schutz nehmen du weißt im fernsehen
läuft stell dir mal vor was auf youtube
los wäre wenn die youtuber so einer
talentshow machen will also sowie reli
und sturm wie früher mit ultra talent
und dann lade hier mal ein und er macht
einfach aus langweiliges und dann
beleidigen die den richtigen machen ihn
richtig fertig auf einer persönlichen
ebene die nur noch auseinander genommen
werden von youtube wieso ist sowas sagen
im fernsehen okay du hast dich hier
geworden bis gekommen weil du davon hast
dass du das gut liefern ganz weil alle
kandidaten kommen hier die liefern die
kriegen eine bewertung ist so viele
wörter verstanden weil ich hätte es dazu
ja auf jeden fall weiterhin eine sehr
angenehm anzusehen der sendung
da muss ich mir auf jeden fall zustimmen
also es ist natürlich gesünder mich in
tränen auszubrechen
ich weiß nicht wie leute von dir jetzt
erst sehen wollt wieder in tränen
ausbricht keine ahnung was diese sendung
ist aber wenn man dann da solche dinge
an den kopf geworfen bekommt finde ich
einen nachfolger sagt ja okay gut ist
mir persönlich nicht so wichtig als dass
man den tränen ausbricht oder so dass
ich gar nicht er soll ich mein tief
wirklich an also das macht alles nicht
so viel sinn oder ich muss sagen auch
nachdem ich das interview auf dem kanal
format sagt mit ihm gesehen habe bin ich
auch nicht schlauer gewesen erleben
irgendwas ist fake war die noch mehr
beleidigt dass irgendein schlaganfall
hatte und deswegen so nicht ganz auf der
höhe es körperlich aber warum ist es
dann so abgelaufen klar wird es reicht
ich werde später kommen
einer der jetzt als schlapp und
beleidigt was ist das für eine sendung
hier sieht man's wieder da hat er die
hörgeräte der hat glaube ich wirklich
nach dem schlaganfall einfach auch
hörvermögen eingebüßt hat motorisches
von in einen bücher so dass er nicht
beschied gehen kann kein wunder bei den
high heels umläuft dass er das war nicht
besonders gut hinbekommt dieses
respektlose weil es hier einfach
hinkommen
ach du das hier was ich höre dir gar
nicht mehr zu ich bin auch scheiße
yahoo das stimmt natürlich also ich will
auch gar nicht rechtfertigen dass man
nämlich respektlos gegenüber leuten ist
das sollte man generell nicht sein aber
ich finde auf der anderen seite geht es
provokationen und der erste angriffe von
der jury eigentlich aus den schon hart
angeht dafür dass halten singen und
tanzen kann wie er darauf reagiert das
möchte auch nicht gut aber muss man
schon so nacheinander sehen aber lasst
uns mal darüber nachdenken leute
angenommen die werden einfach ganz
freundlich zu ihm gewesen hätten einfach
gesagt ja das war nicht so gut tut uns
leid vielleicht probierst du später
nochmal eine gesangs- und tanzstunden
und dann schauen wir noch mal dass wir
eigentlich normaler menschlicher umgang
gewesen aber unterhaltsam also was ist
logische konsequenz man legt sich gäste
ein die möglichst weg sind macht die
dann fertig weil das irgendwie spannend
ist für die zuschauer und angeblich auch
unterhaltsam und ist dass dann das
prinzip von der show wie sie jetzt am
ende dieses dsds videos angelangt und
meine stimmung nach dem schauen dieses
videos ungefähr so als ich muss
eigentlich alles mal in meinem kopf
zusammen ziele und überlege dass da
leute sehr hart angegangen werden in
ihrer würde wie ich persönlich finde
verletzt werden das dann scheinbar noch
einiges außenrum gefegt wird dann kann
ich nicht mehr sagen okay leute ich habe
mit video angeschaut aber das ist nicht
meine sendung aber lasst uns in den
kommentaren das wird hier leute auf
meinen darunter wasser
sollte eine fernsehsendung sein und dann
könnt ihr wie immer hier drüben noch
einen vielleicht persönlich
vorgeschlagenes video abchecken das hat
zwei pro jahr